success can be so many different things
for different people right in my world
for the longest time success was living
in New York and doing what I love which
was being part being one with New York
City instead of being the guy that I am
now colorful and a bit eccentric and
crazy high-kicking Frederick you know
that kind of bubbly personality we all
have when we're with our best friends or
family I locked myself up and I try to
copy other big successful real estate
agents instead of being me the more I'm
me the Mart pull the guard down the more
successful I become what you do to feel
successful to actually authentically
feel successful I think you have to
present yourself in an honest way to the
world and I know a lot of people that
are successful on the outside but maybe
I question how it feels because they
might not be true to themselves you
shouldn't wear a suit because you're
supposed to I mean enter the conference
room the really conservative environment
with my keys big developers and come in
in a t-shirt and really say that I
wearing a t-shirt you know brand that
whatever you're wearing professionally
own it and sell it I have a trademark
which is my high kick and I've been
doing it since I was four years old and
I think that's the key when you talk
about trademark because I think
everybody should have a trademark but it
needs to be authentic - you can't just
be a gimmick that you make up I mean I
heard that Karate Kid think that I stole
it from them but in fact they stole it
from me because at four years old I was
doing that before Karate Kid movie came
around so I'm still waiting for my um my
royalties from them you know I I left
Sweden 13 years ago and I left everybody
that I love my friends and family behind
to become successful in New York yes
real estate and beaks is successful in
real estate at work is important to me
but also equally important to create a
family so I'm gonna be a father soon and
that is a different kind of success